you there are more than 250 proposed
bills in at least 43 states that are
aimed at restricting access to the
ballot
it's being called the new jim crow this
is racial voter suppression
uh you've heard the words jim crow we
don't enjoy
saying it but it is what it is what we
see here
is jim crow 2.0 let's just call it what
it is
and it's embarrassing it's sad
as senator graham just mentioned you
heard a lot of that right the new
georgia laws just
like what existed in the old south so we
thought it's really important to
actually know what happened in the old
south
so what did jim crow laws actually look
like
here's one no colored barber shall have
uh
serve as a barber to white women or
girls all persons licensed to conduct a
restaurant
shall serve either white people
exclusively or colored people
exclusively
it shall be unlawful for a white person
to marry anyone except a white person
here to weigh in as utah congressman
burgess owens congressman
your dad actually grew up
in the jim crow south so when you hear
the constant repetition of georgia is
jim crow
you must have a pretty enraged response
well
my dad did my granddad did and so did i
uh i was 16 years old when i finally had
a chance to
experience meeting white americans
because i grew up in a community was all
segregated a very proud community by the
way and lauren let me say this
i'm sick and tired of this heart left
and you see black elita's putting my
race down
and putting the greatest generation that
ever lived down my dad's generation
my granddad's generation would love our
country and they're all about
meritocracy and
proving that they were worthy of respect
by commanding respect by winning
so to hear that we are hapless hopeless
race no that's that's marxism
that's lies and that's not my that's not
my race that's why
that's not the parents i was raised with
i'm so thankful i grew up around the
people i did
in the 1960s well congressman
they they refused to be referred to as
victims
and instead they acted like champions
and here we have a situation where biden
is demanding that the all-star game
leave atlanta
yeah again let's let's remind everyone
of what jim crow was actually like for
baseball players
in georgia here's what it said it shall
be unlawful for any amateur colored
baseball team
to play baseball in any vacant lot or
baseball diamond within two blocks
of any playground devoted to the white
race
congressman this only illustrates does
it not
why this baseball game absolutely
must be played in georgia it is and let
me just say this i
i came to nfl in 1973 at the time there
were no black quarterbacks black centers
black middle linebackers
because at that time the white men's
leadership positions we've come so far
there is not even an issue
what we have today are people who say
that they are compassionate they love
our uh
my race and another races if they want
to deal with this by the way i've been
hearing about this uh
voter id for 20 years if they cared
about black people getting
getting be able to get on a plane to
have a job to have a savings account
to move into the middle class which
takes an id they would have done
something by now
they love to use miseries as as a
political strategy
and i want my democratic friends to
understand this we have a hard left marx
and the socialists is using your good
hearts
to to destroy our nation don't let them
we got to come together realize we have
the same end game which is to make sure
our kids have the best future possible
we'll all live in safety and that will
never happen with the hard left
that is totally they're godless they
hate uh they hate the family they hate
capitalism
and that's what you see as they destroy
our nation from within so let's not let
them do that my friends
congress congressman just finally how
did we get to a point in time in our
country
where democrats apparently think so
little
of minority voters that they just assume
they don't have ids what is that that is
just so insulting
think about it uh what other race do
they think do you think that the asian
or the
the polish the italian no only the black
people and and here's the
thing they also recognize the black
americans are leaving the plantation
that's why they want these walls to come
down they want this
this surge at the borders and by the way
what what marxists do and it's been a
history of them
is they love chaos it's on purpose they
love to have this
not think about what our future's like
so understand that we're after
and we're not gonna let them get it done
for sure now re-write rewriting history
and tearing it down as well congressman
thank you so much for coming on tonight